Looking at the brain from above, you can see a deep fissure called the longitudinal fissure,
which divides the brain into two cerebral hemispheres.
The surface of these cerebral hemispheres is riddled with many smaller fissures called
sulcai.
The ridges around those sulcai are called gyri.
Sulcai and gyri are formed from the folding of the outermost layer of the brain, the cerebral
cortex.
The cerebral cortex contains important areas devoted to processing sensory information,
important areas for movement, and what are known as association areas, which are regions
where information from other brain areas is integrated to support higher level cognitive functions.
The cerebral cortex is often divided into lobes, with the most common division being into
four lobes, frontal, parietal, occipital, and temporal.
While each lobe contains numerous individual regions, we can identify some important areas
for specific functions in each lobe.
The frontal lobe, for example, contains the motor cortex, an area of the brain that's
critically important for voluntary movement.
The primary motor cortex makes up a large portion of the motor cortex.
Neurons in the primary motor cortex cause movement in the head and body.
The portion of the frontal lobe that's in front of the motor cortex is called the prefrontal
cortex.
The prefrontal cortex is particularly involved in higher level cognitive functions, including
decision making, planning, impulse control, and the ability to act in pursuit of long-term
goals.
Although there are a number of areas of the frontal lobe that are involved in language,
one well-known language area is Broca's area, which is found in the left cerebral hemisphere
in most people.
The precise role of Broca's area in language is still being debated, but it's thought
to be important for language production because damage to the region often disrupts the
ability to produce language.
A sulcus called the central sulcus separates the frontal lobe from the preital lobe.
The preital lobe is involved with a number of functions, including language, spatial orientation
and attention, and it also contains the primary somatosensory cortex, an area of the brain
that's responsible for processing sensations from the body, such as touch, pain, temperature,
and proprioception or awareness of the body's position in space.
The occipital lobe is found at the very back of the brain.
It's primarily associated with visual processing.
The primary visual cortex, the main area for visual processing, is found here, along
with several other visual areas.
The temporal lobe is involved in a number of functions, including higher order processing
of visual information, learning and memory, and hearing.
It contains the primary auditory cortex, which plays a critical role in our ability to perceive sound.
Near the junction between the temporal and preital lobes is another important language
area known as Vernicus area.
Vernicus area is typically associated with language comprehension, although its contribution
to language processing is still being explored.
Extending from the very back and bottom of the brain is the cerebellum.
The cerebellum is best known for its roles in movement, which include motor coordination
and control, balance and posture, fine-tuning of voluntary movements, and movement-related
learning.
When we look at a medial view of the brain, we can see a number of other structures that
were obscured with a lateral view.
We can, for example, clearly see the brainstem, which connects the brain to the spinal cord.
The brainstem contains a number of important pathways that run between the brain and
spinal cord, but it also has many important areas of its own.
The brainstem is divided into three regions, the midbrain, ponds and medulla.
The medulla, or medulla ablangada, is the lowest part of the brainstem found just above
the spinal cord.
One of the important roles linked to the medulla is the regulation of vital functions such
as cardiovascular and respiratory activity.
The ponds contains important pathways that carry information to and from the cerebellum,
and is home to a number of nuclei or clusters of neurons associated with the cranial nerves,
a group of nerves that are involved with sensory and motor functions of the head and
face.
The midbrain is the uppermost portion of the brainstem.
The midbrain contains the two largest dopamine-producing areas in the brain.
One is the substantiate nigra.
Dopamine neurons here play important roles in movement, among other things.
Large numbers of dopamine neurons in the substantiate nigra die in Parkinson's disease, leading to
problems with movement.
The other major dopamine-producing area in the midbrain is called the ventral-tegmental
area or VTA.
Dopamine neurons in the VTA extend to various parts of the brain, one of them being a region
called the nucleus accumbens.
This pathway between the VTA and nucleus accumbens seems to be critically important for rewarding
experiences such as the use of addictive drugs.
The substantiate nigra and nucleus accumbens are also part of a larger group of structures
called the basal ganglia.
The basal ganglia includes several other regions as well, and are involved in movement,
habit formation, and reward processing, among other things.
Above the brainstem is a structure called the phalamus.
The phalamus is often described as a relay station, because a great deal of the information
that proceeds to the cortex first stops the phalamus before being sent onto its destination.
For example, all sensory information exceptal faction travels from sensory receptors to
a nucleus in the phalamus specialized for dealing with that type of sensory data.
Then the information is sent from the phalamus to the appropriate area of the cortex where
it is further processed.
Postearrier to the phalamus is the pineal gland, whose main function is to secrete the
hormone melatonin.
Melatonin plays an important role in regulating circadian rhythms and is primarily secreted
during darkness.
The hypothalamus is found just below the phalamus.
The hypothalamus is involved in a long list of processes, many of which are critically
important to maintaining homeostasis across various bodily systems.
Some of the major functions generally attributed to the hypothalamus include the regulation
of, thirst and drinking behavior, hunger and feeding, body temperature, stress responses,
circadian rhythms, and more.
One of the ways the hypothalamus helps to regulate all of these functions is through its
connections to the pituitary gland, a hormone secreting gland that sits just below the hypothalamus.
The pituitary gland produces a number of hormones, such as growth hormone, thyroid stimulating
hormone, follicle stimulating hormone, and luteinizing hormone, which it releases in response
to signals from the hypothalamus.
The pituitary gland also secreates two hormones, oxytocin and vasopressin, which are made in
the hypothalamus and sent down to the pituitary gland to be released into the bloodstream.
The hippocampus is found in the temporal lobe, but was not visible with the lateral view
of the brain we used earlier when discussing the temporal lobe.
Typically, the hippocampus will be surrounded by brain tissue, but in this image, its
approximate location is highlighted.
The hippocampus has many functions, but is best known for its role in memory.
It seems to be especially important for turning short-term memories into long-term memories.
A adjacent to the hippocampus is the amygdala, an almond-shaped structure known for its
role in emotion.
The amygdala is most well known for processing fear and responding to threats in the environment,
but it is also involved in other emotions, including positive emotions such as pleasure.
This sea-shaped area is called the corpus colosum.
The corpus colosum is the largest bundle of axons in the brain, and it connects the left
and right cerebral hemispheres, enabling communication between them to occur.
There is a system of cavities found throughout the brain.
These hollow spaces are called ventricles.
Specialized membranes in the ventricles produce cerebral spinal fluid, or CSF.
CSF performs a number of important functions for the brain.
For example, it surrounds the brain, forming a protective layer, and suspending the brain
in fluid, which reduces the strain forces like gravity would have on the brain.
It also removes waste products from the brain, and helps to regulate the extracellular
environment of neurons.